it's a big fat lie they just they taught
this to scare women and to make them
think once again that they're putting
victims and so that they're victims of
men and so feminists are the last people
in the world you want to take any advice
or information from about men
specifically or marriage today is a
long-form interview actually with the
lady I'm very glad to have on the show
she's made around for a while but she's
had some articles recently at the
Federalist and washing the examiner that
caught my eye you can follow her on the
twitter at suzanne venker suzanne van
kirk aam she's the author of the book
women who win it love but what really
caught my eye recently wasn't one to
make sure I get the title this article
right ladies stop trying to have sex
like men did I say Susan Suzanne how are
you goodness I'm fine no you said
Suzanne okay thank God I made sure that
I read it here that's one of the rare
instances where I go down to my notes
because Susan Suzanne you know have a
thing about that in rightfully so well I
do get called Susan I don't usually
respond but this time I thought I'd
correct well thank you I appreciate it
and one time someone actually called me
Stefan because some people spell at pH
and I said well ha not only am I not
Stefan I don't even spell it that way so
you would be error writing and then
correcting turns out he was dyslexic as
well this was an actual guy in a comedy
club would introduce me on his fault so
Suzanne miss venker really appreciate a
lot of the continent you've put out
there and you were booked for this show
before Alyssa Milano one intersex
striker which we'll get to in a second
what a coincident the article ladies
stop trying to have sex like men for
people I want you to describe it for
people but let me kind of recap what I
got from it you deal with what you sort
of presupposes an intellectual fallacy
in that women are as sexually predatory
as men which is kind of a tenet of
modern feminism or or at least that's
what a lot of feminists want to be
correcting where I have that wrong and
why right about that at this point in
time yeah huge reason to write about
that it's all changed and not because
people have changed but because society
and the culture has with respect to the
messages and the narrative that is sent
to modern women about
sex which is essentially part and parcel
of the larger feminist message which is
that there are no differences between
men and women that whatever differences
you think you see are just a social
construct or the way that parents have
you know foolishly raised their children
and that to accept this means to
understand that we need to upend society
and and do things very differently so
that we can achieve so-called equality
in this man and the social construct
that's when women's studies became
gender studies correct oh yes absolutely
because Alyssa Milano actually what she
was just apologizing because someone
said listen not all women have P not a
woman have vagina some have penises
she's like oh my god if I can correct it
I'm sorry so I mean that's got to be
pretty tough even for the feminist women
out there who would disagree with you
well I just I've steered clear so far of
the whole that issue because that's
taking it to like a whole nother level
right I'm still back on really the
remnants of the 1960s feminist movement
which is still very much with us today
in fact it's so with us it's not even a
movement it's just embedded into society
and accepted as a fait accompli so the
idea of a quality meaning sameness hmm
has fully taken hold to the point where
people don't appreciate or understand or
just even grasp the vast differences
between women and men and how they're
meant to work together right as a whole
to complement and so what we have right
now are women effectively competing with
men because they think they need to be
more masculine to get this so-called
equal world right um so the sex piece is
very I'd like to focus on that if we if
we may for a second because a lot of
people we've talked about this quite a
bit with Karen strong and and Cassie J
about sort of the myth of the the the
income inequality the wage gap you know
things like that but specifically
sexually I mean we had Naomi wolf on the
show she said well women like to have
sex - well that's not really the
argument we're making we're talking
about a different I guess sort of
intellectual and emotional
interpretation processing of the way men
and women handle sexual and
at least that's what the argument that
I'm making when I talk about this could
you give us some specifics on that how
do men and women differ specifically
when it comes to sex and what do you
think the biggest lie is that's been
pushed regard okay so the biggest lie is
exactly what you just said the Naomi
Wolf types will suggest that women are
no different from men in this regard and
of course they do come to the table with
a completely different set of needs and
expectations when it comes to that that
topic now first of all there's there's a
physical reality that women's bodies are
saturated in oxytocin which is known as
the bonding known among psychologists as
the bonding hormone and men do have
oxytocin as well but a much smaller
amount they're much more favored with
testosterone which is a different
hormone altogether and so you have the
fizzy the physiological differences
between them and what happens with even
with sexually liberal women who and this
is all coming out in the book this year
that I've co-authored with John Townsend
who has been who's a professor who's
been studying this for years and the
research shows that even very sexually
liberal women who want to you know buy
into the narrative of yeah you know sex
is great doesn't matter whether you're
you know in a relationship or not just
just having it is what matters they will
enter with that mindset and then have
sex and be very confused about why the
next day they're still thinking about
that person in that event event in terms
of its future capacity in a way that the
man isn't necessarily doing and not
understanding why that is what to play
devil's advocate they would argue that
that's sort of societal conditioning
right that that's guilt same thing as
this idea of being abstinent when I
talked with Amy Schumer I guess it ended
up at being a debate on Fox News eight
nine years ago which didn't really age
that welfare that was the argument that
this is societal conditioning once woman
had the pill and once they were told
that they didn't know they no longer
needed to be a byproduct this
conditioning they could be as sexually
promiscuous in predatory as men because
that's a that's a I guess a freedom that
they wanted to enjoy and if there's
anything that proves that to be utterly
false of course it's the me2 movement
because why would we have
now when I talk about the me2 movement I
don't mean the necessary takedown of
certain powerful men who deserved a fall
I mean all the the repercussions after
that of the bad dates and how it went
wrong we wouldn't have that conversation
or that even the circumstances would
even come up if women were really
genuinely just like men because that
confusion wouldn't be there after the
fact right like that Aziz Ansari case
with I don't fully understand in that
case it seems to me that I'd like to
have a hand in his mouth which just was
weird I don't even get the sexual
proclivities I don't even like I
understand some things I'm like what's
attractive about that yeah no no it's a
perfect example because this is a show
you chose you saw the ride you bought a
ticket there destined to be really sort
of the premise itself is conflicted kind
of going to the lisam in milano this
idea of a sex strike from feminists it
assumes that withholding sex would
disproportionately affect men which
wouldn't really matter if we both wanted
sex equally I mean do you deal what my
wife would do if I said you know what
for that now you get no sex for two
weeks she laughs or ass off and go to
Costco we don't like to talk about this
it's a really unpopular topic to admit
that women will hear there's a sleep
study recently done I still have to
write about it where men and women were
recently asked whether they would rather
have sex or sleep these days with what's
going on in the world today and women by
and large chose sleep over sex or as men
didn't so the the idea that women
especially women with children and jobs
and all of the rest so the solution is
that for the man to have sex and the
wife to be sleeping this is what you're
as incorrect I want to make sure I'm
understanding this but the point is
everywhere you look in every study the
differences are clear and they're there
but they're not popular right because
they go against the narrative that men
and women are absolutely equal or could
be if society would just get out of the
way and let them show how equal they
really can be or say I shouldn't say
equal the same because that's really
what we're talking about yeah well I
think it's also important that I know
that you
recognize this that people can have our
couples husbands and wives can have
equally important roles but they're not
the same they are not equal in the
sameness but they're equally important
so that's really the crux of
understanding what's happened with
feminism and how it's affected people
today is exactly what you just said the
whole premise of it was that you can't
be considered quote/unquote equal unless
you're doing the same tasks but that
could only be believed by somebody who
so clearly devalued the work of one of
the one of those two works you know one
of the two tasks well and of course it's
always been about motherhood let's face
it it's about taking care of kids in the
house because they diminished that role
that the feminist mind has so little
regard for that role that's how they
manage to get other people to also have
that same view because if you don't
happen to share that you're not gonna
have any resentment because you believe
so fully that what you're doing is of
equal value if not more then holding a
job right so it's only people who are
insecure about that that value and then
were you know told over and over Via
Media in every possible way whether it's
the news media or television or movies
or what-have-you
that this is the lesser than role full
that said yeah that's not I want to go
do what's what's valued and it's human
nature to want to be valued for what you
do women used to be valued for that role
but feminists took all that away by
valuing the Paycheck over the
relationships and the connections and
the home and so that's what caused
people to jump on board because they
wanted to be back value right well they
would push back and say well we just
want we wanted to value the choice of a
woman to choose a career versus
motherhood just as red making it just as
readily available as a man so why push
back against that I know you know that
some of the left they've painted you as
someone who's letting men off the hook
and telling women that it's all their
fault so what negative effects or would
you have any data that you could point
to as far as this sort of sexual
liberation specifically as it relates to
sex and gender roles and relationships
what ramifications if we say well well
there's ramifications for sure but real
quickly if it were true
that that it was just all about choice
right then here you are 30 40 years
later all the choices are right before
you right women have gonna have anything
they want in terms of their lives and
even witness and even penises and even
with that as jordan peterson has has
pointed out over and over the the the
the countries with the most gender
equality on paper you know what Sweden
and Scandinavian countries the more you
have the opportunity for choice to do
whatever you know the more more the
opportunities there the more likely you
are to see those sex differences show up
so the whole theory the whole feminist
theory has been completely shattered
some forty years later by proving in
fact that 70 cents on the dollar proves
they think it proves discrimination of
course in fact forty years later if you
have all that choice and you still have
that disconnect in salary that's clearly
a choice because you have the
opportunity now and you're still
choosing it so the idea that you would
just choose it if you had the
opportunities and holding up does the
same apply to sex and that women have 4x
4x women have sex more freely available
to them I don't know what 4x is they
have no sex more freely available but
they tend to try and stay within the
confines of a more monogamous
relationship it did you know some so
with respect to sex itself it's it's so
hard we're still piecing through
everything that's happening really
because when you talk about this hookup
culture which is so awful because women
have been there's there's a lot more
reasons as to why they're engaging in
this behavior and it's only in part
because they're well it's not an just in
part it's it's the whole enchilada but
there's different pieces to the whole
concept of mapping out your life like a
man's and being just like a man if you
if you're going to postpone marriage
inevitably ok 10 years out to where
women used to do it and you're focused
on the career well most people are going
to want to have sex you know before
they're 30 I know you were exception
you had that great I love that article
that was great no I wasn't certain we
got we got married when we were 24 and I
talked about how it yeah was a it was it
was very good yeah yeah I loved your
article I thought it was great I'm sure
was very difficult and more power to you
but most people unless they marry
younger like that if you marry at 22 23
24 25 much more doable in my opinion for
the average person at least as a sales
point to sell it then if you're gonna
wait to you're 32 or 33 right that's
gonna be a lot harder so the abstinence
idea works really well if you marry
younger but you can't really call for
that and say oh yeah marry in your 30s
that's never gonna fly right so but
that's the message women are getting
that you marry later so of course what
are you gonna do in the meantime you're
gonna have a lot of sex you're gonna
have a lot of different relationships
that you're gonna move in and out of and
my argument is that that's ultimately
very disruptive in my opinion to
specifically women but I think men and
women too because I think a lot of men
would like to find women who would like
to get married and settle down but now
they're finding women are more
aggressive than they are and then in the
sex department yeah that's another
consequence of this this narrative yeah
we just had a letter about that in a
life advice and yesterday where he uh he
was a virgin and she was not she was
previously married and she was into some
stuff that he was uncomfortable with and
he was asking for advice I'm like you
know I haven't really run into this
before but um my advice is don't take
anything off the table because you don't
know in 15 years if you might want that
on the table so uh talk it out but um
what what negative ramifications I guess
would you point to specifically so let's
assume okay a woman is postpone marriage
indefinitely and she's having sex with
more partners than before the 1960s
through today um like well if you were
to make the case to a young woman what
would you say are the benefits to not to
being abstinent or at least keeping sex
reserved for a serious long-term
relationship oh gosh well I I know these
are very macro questions like why would
it be good to find someone you love I
know it's tough to but I'm trying to
give you enough Lane disk because I
always open with the same question if I
were talking to a young woman what do
you want what is the end goal that is
such an important question especially
today because I don't think we think far
beyond tomorrow
cuz of the way the world is today you
got to go for the long term and think
about your life as a whole what are you
going for and ultimately you're gonna
find me most people want to say even if
they're not ready for or think they're
ready for marriage they at least want to
be in a long-term committed relationship
with somebody who loves them and they
love back that they can count you know a
written in other words a relationship as
opposed to not a relationship okay well
here's how that works there's a thing
called dating it used to be called
courtship right and that's called
getting to know the person date by date
by date by date until you're way in and
the relationship isn't established you
fall in love and then invariably the bed
will will come into play there now
whether you do that before marriage or
not at this point I'm just happy if
people just wait until the relationship
is very established which is why in my
upcoming book one of the I have a list
of eight dating roles and one of them is
don't have sex with him on the first
second or twenty at the date and when
I've told this to the younger generation
Millennials are younger it's it's as if
I've said don't have sex before marriage
it's equivalent to that because the idea
that you would wait twenty dates and the
20 dates the whole point of saying that
is just its initial shock value but the
point is exactly what I just said for
the relationship the bond comes first
the sex isn't inevitable once the bond
is there but you don't get you don't put
the cart before the horse because
invariably you're it's not gonna work
out long-term so well what about people
who say what if you're sexually
incompatible that you bond beforehand
then you find out that you're you're not
compatible sexually that's a very common
argument yeah so I've had you know you
might have a different take on this
since you were abstinent before so you'd
have a better first-hand take on that I
suppose but I always argue that I didn't
say you have to necessary you're married
right so if you want to determine that
prior to marriage right you know figure
that out shortly before right you know
like once you're in but I also happen to
think that it's a very natural thing
that you can it
I think it's a weak argument it's not
rocket science typically speaking I
would imagine more so for women in the
sense that if they find a man who was
attracted to typically angry aggressive
feminist types he might be a selfish
lover yeah well there's a prophecy then
why'd you get with them to begin with
right but but but but you know I think
the sexual attraction chemistry is comes
way before I don't know what I can say
on this show no you can see you can say
whatever you want you can say honestly
whatever whatever you want I said penis
like five times you've already put the
penis in the vagina whoa not every woman
has a vagina that's the problem it's not
the words it's the premise I don't agree
with it neither would Alyssa that's what
I call Milano continued before that
happens
you already know whether you have
chemistry you don't need to do that
specific thing to know the chemistry you
sit down across from somebody on a date
and you'll know like that whether or not
you're you're attracted to each other a
few dates in you're still gonna know I
mean you you know and presumably you're
you know kissing and whatnot and you can
determine this sexual attraction without
that specific act right that's a good
point you know I mentioned before the
the angry warriors coming like I said my
wife and I were completely abstinent for
each other and before that I school
lived a full life but that's why it was
so hard to for my wife and I because we
said listen we want to want to be
consistent with our values and was of
course wildly sexually attracted to her
this idea that it's easy I mean it's
it's not easy it's not easy for men it's
also not easy for women that being said
it wasn't easy because we were a loving
committed relationship I think it would
have been pretty easy for my wife or she
would tell you was never a struggle to
fend off one-night stands that came
pretty naturally to her but once we were
in a relationship it was a struggle for
both of us yes it is it's very hard and
so some people will make it in some
people will not but at this point like I
said we're so far out of the gate on
that
I'm just happy if people just associate
sex with bond commitment relationship
and not entertainment right I mean
that's really what I'm going for
that's what I'm interested in especially
for this younger generation and I
think they don't understand the
connection because they don't they don't
have anybody who's telling them to wait
or two that that comes later they think
that there's they think there's no
cleanup there's kind of a split there's
kind of a split between the I guess you
would say sort of the far left
progressive feminists who just say have
free sex you have a birth you know birth
control pill put on a sailor's condom of
course at the taxpayer expense they need
to pay is right for all of these
countries different roles include
exactly sixteen out of a twenty one for
Hobby Lobby is not enough that's clearly
oppression of women we have not reached
yet the stage of choice I remember what
my put was like talking about before
this I just started thinking about
having a lot of you doing I have known
you wait that you waited it was hard and
well yeah careful poor choice of words
but oh this was gonna be Mike you wrote
another article I think was a Washington
Examiner about the positive societal
effects and I've talked about this quite
a bit listen when you tell oh sorry but
I was saying the far progressive left
let me get to that next point let me put
that on the shelf and then you have sort
of the in cells the people on the right
who have just you know they've taken
part in this exodus because they're
afraid of women a lot of men or they've
been rejected by women they feel they've
been mistreated by women you know but
it's not necessarily voluntary and then
you have a lot of men who sort of reject
this idea of long term relationships and
that leads to the hook-up culture and
there aren't many people saying hey
listen there's there's a place for
complement complementary roles in
relationships and waiting is a good
thing for both of you a lot of people
saying well hey you know what women are
now acting like [ __ ] so now go out and
be a CAD and I think that's an important
point to make and you write in your
articles about the positive societal
benefits there including fewer
fatherless households I mean we've
talked about this in the show maybe you
can educate them a little more than I
was prepared to free health care and
education the idea of a nuclear family
would solve a lot more of society's woes
so I would say that's probably really
more at the core of why I do what I do
and what my real ultimate message is
it's a it's really about saving the
family but that's too big of a that's
too lofty of a goal so I have to break
it down but that's really ultimately
what what I'm talking about because
there's a direct connection between our
new attitude towards sex and what's you
have to take that and break it down to
what's happened as a result of that
and so I did I connected it to
fabulousness saying so ultimately the
fewer the more you're embracing this
idea that sex is not for me to forget
marriage at this point that it's not
even connected to a bond in a
relationship is to essentially move away
from any sort of courtship or marriage
or dating dating rituals that would lead
to marriage and I'm saying look the goal
for most people don't ask it's feminists
because they don't care but for normal
people they want to get married and have
families they just I mean that's the
fact
in fact 99% people are going to do that
if you interview ask them at least they
want to do that so what's the best way
to get there and so if you're
relationship oriented and your marriage
oriented your every choice that you make
sexually is going just happen with your
microphone there I think you might need
to your your headphone jack or something
I apologize you sound like I don't know
what's happening what's going on there
maybe unplug it and reap yeah plug it
back in sir it's like deaf Punk let me
keep give me a yes that's better see
yeah you started sound like Daft Punk
there for a second
no sorry continue what the point you're
making about about it obviously being
important to preserve marriages if if
your goal is marriage then the decisions
that you make early on are all
predicated on that goal so and that
includes sex and in terms of I mean
everything what you choose to study in
school and it clerks certainly with the
kind of guys or gals you're going to go
out with is gonna be depending on what
your ultimate goal is so since most
people want to get married I'm saying
then make a connection between the
choices that you're making early on as
opposed to thinking that you're gonna
worry about that later
and so if you're postponing marriage and
you're moving in out of relationships
and just having sex more casually than
clearly that has something to do with
why fewer marriages are being formed to
begin with because by the time and
here's the kicker by the time women get
into their 30s their market value their
mate value I mean declines
whereas men's riots now nobody wants to
talk about this and this is going to be
in my book but men
as they get older become more attractive
because they're getting more established
in their careers and in their lives and
have it takes men longer to mature than
women so by the time they there mark
their mate value Rises when they get
older but as women get older especially
their 30s those men the same age are
often looking for younger women more
fertile women more attractive when they
become sexy like Silver Fox it's sort of
like Timothy Olyphant
I mean I am a straight man but I see him
with the silver hair and I say as I see
the Grays coming in well I just going
for the Timothy Olyphant look if some
guys really pull it off not that women
become physically less attractive in the
30s that's not what I'm suggesting but
you know men tend to be a little more
awkward a little later in life right and
as they get more established they become
more attractive and this is I mean the
research is there it's not me you know
it's that's what's how it's always been
and it's still that way and even with
this so-called equal world that we live
in women still look for men who are
stable and who they can know that they
can count on should they choose to bow
out of the workforce down the road which
by the way most do that's another big
farce that feminists sell about the
number of mothers what is the percentage
we're in the reference women who drop
out of the workforce so right now like
what you'll hear in the media is 70% of
mothers with children under 18 are in
the workforce and that's technically
true what they don't tell you is that
the vast majority of that group work
part-time so if you connect so if you
combine the mothers who work part-time
with the mothers who don't work at all
which is about a quarter of mothers
married mothers now we're talking on
married mothers of course okay then then
you get the majority of married mothers
who are actually home full-time or home
full-time and have part-time work on the
side which could mean you know anything
as little as five hours a week it could
be an Etsy shop where you sell some
where you sell some seaweed soap yep
by the way they shout out to my I see a
lady who sells seaweed soap it's
wonderful yes I
support etsy I support the little guy
because I'm not the party at big misses
or small business I'm the party of Etsy
store fronts that I would never walk
into if they were physical storefronts
for fear of my own person and that's a
perfect that's a perfect example of
businesses you would just you would lump
that person in who has a business maybe
she opened up a shop after her kids were
all in school and she works during the
hours that her kids are in school you
cannot lump that person in with a mother
of three two children under five who's
in the work force full-time year-round
you just can't do that no you kids are
two totally different life and it's also
not fair to compare that career arc to
say you know dr. ben Carson who was
separate and conjoined twins at that
time it's like one takes a little bit
more commitment and means that he
probably needs a woman who can help
support that role because it's a very
high pressure high time value scenario
but then that goes back to what we were
saying at the beginning about devaluing
that non-renew Maury today it does not
you know if you don't have accolades and
a paycheck it's completely dismissed in
this country it didn't used to be that
way before feminism came along to do
that do it I mean we we exalted mothers
that's a that's a good point you know I
look at it sort of as a almost planning
for life after college it is kind of a
crazy when you think about how much time
we spend thinking and planning and of
course instilling and children that well
it's very important to pick your major
it's very important to figure out what
you want to do in life but something
that will affect more people and most
kids change their majors but most people
will want to get married in particularly
women we don't spend nearly as much time
telling them to plan for that portion of
their life which will be more fulfilling
and more impactful I do I think it's
extremely rare I mean I don't know of
anybody who really goes out and tells
them one-on-one look here's the deal
don't listen to this don't listen this
media is you're going to you basically
my overall message is if you listen to
the culture and follow its narrative you
will fail in life and in love you will
fail because everything they teach you
is going to land you in this it's good
to dead-end road and it's because they
won't talk about these truths these
politically incorrect truths about for
example the difference between women and
men and how they want different things
how they bring different things to the
table here's a perfect example in the
last week there's been two articles
about the
of the amount of work that single montly
married mothers have to do on the home
front compared to their single mom
counterparts and since single moms don't
have to do the reason single moms don't
have to do as much work as married moms
it's because of that dreaded father
slash husband who's in the house who
causes more work for her so then they
hailed single motherhood as well it's
not so bad after all in the end actually
is really great because ABCD birth of
course no no conversation about the
children I'm assuming they didn't Paul
the kids in that Rachel from friends
about the children yeah no I think and I
will say this um and I I don't see what
all is letting men off the hook or this
idea that your di I see you as truly
looking at the idea of choice and
wanting to value all work provided from
both men and women but I will say this a
lot of these lies from modern feminists
they do seem to instill a false sense of
confidence or value in certain choices
for women for example if you get a
career you will be fulfilled and I will
say that as a general rule in my
experience they instill fear and a lot
of young men and I'll say I had to deal
with this because I work full time when
I work really long hours and my wife and
I've had these conversations we're going
to be having kids a little bit later in
life just because of my career I was
really afraid for a long time and I'll
tell you why a big part of it was
because you see all the time in the
media think oh he gets home from work
and he thinks that's all he has to do
and in my head I'm going oh my gosh yeah
after working a 12 14 hour a day I
really probably am NOT gonna have the
juice of me to do dishes to do that much
laundry and yeah it's gonna kind of be
necessary that someone else helps me
with that but a lot of men feel as
though all of the above are expected of
them and I think they feel the weight
whether it's accurate or not they
certainly feel the weight of the world
on their shoulders absolutely and of
course you don't you can't hear this in
the media cuz it's taboo the reality is
that women's work at home has actually
declined this just came out at PU last
week the women's and because of course
convenience foods and Technology and all
of this has made it easier at home for
women right but the expectations for men
is that they yeah yeah the expectation
for men is that they do more
but they don't work fewer hours than
they did so so women are women work
fewer hours than men they have less
housework at home
men are not working fewer hours and are
expected to pick up more at home so it
doesn't come out in the wash because
ultimately the real problem is that
you're trying to have two people working
your hours that you just described
Stephen to parents working your hours
with little kids under five forget about
it
mayhem yeah and this study doesn't want
to say that's the reason why your that's
the reason why your life there's no time
in the day bottom line right dad
well I can give you sort of anecdotally
right now my wife has gone her my
father-in-law a great man he says I
talked about a son he had sepsis and he
has to undergo the surgery right now and
so she's gone to help her help my
mother-in-law and so she's gone for
about a week about a week and a half and
I'm able to do everything you know we
have two dogs do the laundry do that do
the dishes make sure I take care of my
own meals also do this program but it's
difficult and I certainly missed my wife
and one of the biggest arguments we got
into in the last couple weeks and really
when you look back and it's we're just
kind of wires were crossed it was a good
thing and I think there's one of those
toxic lies from feminism as a man and
one of the most toxic lies using that
word yeah I guess ironically you're
toxic is that men want to dominate women
men want you know women to submit in a
way that is disrespectful when the truth
is the big argument we got into she was
leaving not only for a father-in-law but
she's a bachelorette party coming up
she's been on the road quite a bit and
some of them were trips to help me we
look cottage we're finally actually
getting in a small lake up north and we
kind of got into an argument I said well
you know what maybe kind of going for
would be good if you could be a round
homo more I've been traveling a lot and
she got a little bit upset you said well
I was doing this and I'm traveling and
this is for you and I said yeah but you
know what I but what I really want is my
wife and that's because I love my wife
and I want my wife around and it hurts
when she's gone a lot and that's not
just the convenience thing and this idea
that the anger comes from a place of
wanting to dominate my wife it's I think
a lot of men inherently are are hurt by
it in the vilification I don't even I'm
51 I've never met a man who thinks like
that including my own father was born
19:22 it's a big fat lie they just they
taught this to scare women and to make
them think once again that they're
putting victims and so that they're
victims of men
the average husband and I'll say husband
here as opposed to just man because
there's a big difference yeah when you
marry once you've made that choice
everybody changes women and men both
change when they become husbands and
wives and then again when they become
mothers and fathers and a husband's
mindset is to help and serve and work
with his wife not to hold her down
and anyway I mean that to say that you
can't find somebody like that but I had
seriously yet to meet that person that's
how rare he is in my opinion today
whether he was that way in the day I
don't even I even take issue with the
fact that it was that dominat back in
the day because I don't think men are
that's not who they are and so feminists
are the last people in the world you
want to take any advice or information
from about men specifically or marriage
or motherhood for that matter that's not
their area of expertise well it was now
what about these women who would point
out and I think it might have been the
Young Turks who said well clearly
Suzanne is a hypocritical because she's
written X amount of books and she works
and she's a professional so she doesn't
believe what she's saying because look
at the look at that which is kind of a
complement to your catalogue of work but
still you know you're a horrible human
being no I'm happy to talk about that I
used to get asked that a lot
I must have clarified it a while because
it's been a while since I've had to so
every decision I have ever made has been
with the focus of my family at the
center and so marriage and motherhood
was going to be it for me it was always
gonna be it for me I actually was
married before no kids for four years in
my 20s and much of the reason why we
divorced is because of this um different
priorities different timelines and
values and what had not but I saw that
it wasn't going to work out with this
value system that I had in the in the
end so which is why it ended in the end
um but I started making choices about
this early on in college before anybody
else was I would talk about marriage in
college and I was probably the only one
who did if they thought that was crazy
but no if I'm looking at my life
long-term I got to make choices so what
did I choose for a profession I said I
became a teacher initially that's what I
did in my 20s that was choice number one
living in the Midwest instead of the
East Coast which is where I was was
choice number two because it's much more
doable to raise a family there and uh
financially and then I left teaching
when I was pregnant with my first to go
home and do tutoring you can tutor from
your home for a few extra bucks right
and so that was my plan and that's what
I did and then it was when I was home
with her that I wrote my first book I
ended up stopping the tutoring and and I
wrote this book and I was able to do
that around her schedule because I had
one child and then once the second one
came along three years later I was out
of commission for the next five years
because once you have two you no longer
have that nice little schedule
especially if one of them is nice one of
them as evil as is my theory with the
Olsen twins I don't remember which one's
evil but I know one of them is yes mix
around well my son wasn't evil but he
was a handful and it was way harder with
him so he took up all my time and that's
why I didn't have a third but at any
rate so so I was able to work my work
schedule around her sleeping and her
naps early on and then I was like
incognito and then when they were both
back in kindergarten I picked up and
wrote the next book so everything I've
never known a there's no daycare not
saying my husband works full-time always
has he's the breadwinner so yes I make
money yes I have a career and you and
I'm not telling people you can't do that
figure out a way to do that around your
other priority if that's going to be
your priority so I am actually living
proof not that I'm a hypocrite but that
actually can be done if you're creative
and resourceful and what-have-you and
you seem like a pretty strong-willed
woman you something almost wrong
opinions I think the left might imagine
your husband is sort of a cagney
character coming home and giving you the
old one-two holding your wrists because
you know there isn't there isn't
beef stew in the pot but what is your
relationship like how does your husband
handle obviously you being in the
limelight um well the short answer is
he's extremely supportive because he
believes in everything that we'd have
the exact same value system I mean it's
it's just it could not see almost though
that's important when
and mate as opposed to both liking the
same movies or you know snapchat filters
every every decision we've made has been
with family first
even with his job choices so so that's
what binds us unquestionably so so he
supports everything that I do as far as
are we definitely do have different
personalities um but then there's parts
of our personalities are very similar
and so we we did this a lot which by the
way was why I wrote my last book the
alpha females guide to men and marriage
because that is part memoir and it sort
of tells my story of inadvertently send
that book to my wife let me give you
some send that book to my wife and write
a nice private note because a court of
like you know this my wife is no
shrinking violet and sometimes she'll
come in for exams with work sometimes
like we're moving into a new space and
she helps decorate but every now and
then she comes in and she like
overstepped her bounds because she
doesn't work for the company she never
has she just comes in to help support me
enough to look at her like sweetie this
person is my manager star front stop it
I'm not trying to dominate you I just
don't want you to yeah and that's it's
all about turning it off like being you
know understanding that there's there's
a time and place and so if you happen to
have a very strong personality which I
do that has worked very well for me in
the marketplace
I'm questionably it has not worked well
for me in my marriage so I finally we
have come to Jesus party about this I
guess you could say and we had to work
out how both of us were doing this
because we are both wanting to be heard
if you would you can once put that way
and then marry that with masculinity and
femininity and how that works best so
it's sort of a combination of
personality analysis mixed with
biological sex differences and how in a
marriage things work best to make it
really smooth and easy and it took me
it's great now but it took a long time
because I had a mother who never did
turn it off and it was very bad so
that's and that's not even the speak of
wives with penises we'll put that on the
Shelf right now
there's a whole different can of penises
let me ask you so final if you were to
give one final word of advice right you
have young men and women in college
right now what is it that a man should
do in order to make himself more
attractive not only more attractive but
a more capable and loving husband to
make himself more valuable I should say
to a future wife mate and what is it
that a woman could do to make herself
most valuable so that they both found
what they're looking for that's a great
question so I would take men in a room
separately from women for sure and tell
them I'm a big believer in single sex
education I'm here the comment section
now but yes I've done my least popular
view is I don't think I think that you
should have to sign I think it should be
the exception rather than the rule for
men and women to train at the gym
together and I'll tell you why I think
there are probably more Affairs between
women and men and personal trainers than
any other facet of the workplace I've
watched a woman doing the open and
closed machine and a guy right and I'm
like one two counting all the way up to
2 to 23 am i first off why did you
choose 23 reps no one needs to do 23
reps of that second I was hoping that
her husband would walk in and kick his
ass all right let me go back to the
question separate single room okay
I would tell men that this is gonna be
really difficult because all they've
heard their whole lives especially if
they're in their company if they're in
college now because they're not very old
and been around very long but all they
have heard is that women essentially my
argument is that women have said we want
to rule the world basically we want
everything to be different than the way
that it was 50 years ago so we're gonna
supplant the male role or at least join
you and the men heard that is like okay
well men are not meant to fight with
women they do not want to fight with you
they want to love you they want to serve
you they want to take care of you and
you've basically said you want to do
what they do and so they have in my
opinion lowered their aspirations to
make room for the women and because
women are so aggressive now it's it's
it's it's sort of a mess because men
don't know how to how to behave if you
will what's happened is they've softened
and the women aren't liking that but the
reason why the men of soften is because
basically they thought that's what women
want it because they thought women
wanted to be like the men so what are
the men gonna have to do you can't both
be that way so they took a step back
women aren't happy with them because
they don't want soft men and when and
men are afraid to be aggressive because
the culture tells them that's terrible
their talk so to distill it down you're
looking young I don't know young Apple
young ahi tuna whatever the hell the
names are for celebrity boys at this
point look go ahead don't be afraid to
assert yourself you need to still a find
your way in life find what you want to
do irrespective of what the women around
you do just do you know find what you
love find a path that works for you and
don't be afraid to go after it and not
pay attention to how that affects the
women around you and don't be afraid to
be assertive with them okay or in
general despite the fact that you're
being told that you're sexually
harassing them now that's not to say
that they should I mean you really do
have to be careful today so I'm I'm not
none of no one here is advocating sexual
harassment if you already have a pre-set
vinyl casting couch with a peel off
cover that means you're probably going
the wrong direction okay so that's okay
we don't need to get big I'm not that
quiet my now single sex female locker
room penis is notwithstanding the advice
to young women to make for them to make
themselves as valued and as fulfilled in
their life what advice would you give
number one what is important to you now
is very likely not going to be important
to you ten years from now know that in
advance as you get older a family is
going to become your focus so whatever
this career is that you're building now
keep it in perspective most people do
not have careers anyway they have jobs
and even the ones that do have careers
like you've described yours it's all in
it's like 13 14 15 hours a day and that
is your life so you don't have any other
life and while you're building it that's
all fine and dandy but just know that
once you have children that's not going
to work so you're gonna have to start
planning now by putting your work in
perspective of your personal life and
your
marriage and motherhood if that indeed
is your goal so that's a professional
opinion that I would give as far as the
love side clearly I have a lot of
negative things to say about casual sex
and hookup culture which i think is
horribly destructive so I would what I
want to do and what I want to tell them
what I plan to tell them is it's time to
date again
you need to learn how to how to have
actual relationships with men without
your phones and actual going out on a
date and that means letting him call you
or ask you out and actually have actual
date he pays for it I mean I actually
have a list of this in the in the book
that's coming out it's gonna seem so
retro for young people today and yet
it's an anger a lot of hipsters like
this is an ironically retro it's just
retro retro it's gonna be interesting
and yet fast-forward 10 years down the
road and there and they are gonna want
that man to have the competency and that
and the confidence to take charge of his
life and be a leader yeah you're not
setting them up that way because you're
trying to try to lead instead you know
what it's this base this is going to
sound trust me there's a segue here it's
for this reason I don't wear hoodies now
I used to wear hoodies a lot because I
was often you know with work I was
coming from the gym and so I would often
have a hooded sweater on and I know
quarterblack personally attend a lot of
people think it was a turning point was
Trayvon and Zimmerman no but that did
help but I just I realize another man a
second that no men grown men who I
respect we're uh like hoodies to work I
said you know any any any instance where
there's a hoodie I could just wear a non
hooded sweater and just look a little
bit more like my father and it really
was a conscious decision because I felt
like I was dressed in a boy band I'm
actually glad you brought up clothing
because I think it's been a huge letdown
for women to stop wearing dresses and
men to stop wearing suits
I think the automatic respect that came
from that attire you didn't even have to
earn it you just walked in the room I
mean right now when my husband puts on a
suit I
immediately feel differently about him I
just do then if he's wearing his slob
clothes and he does with me when I when
I have it like if I put a dress on
instead of pants it is like a magnet
there's something about I mean the skirt
it's the skirt it's all about the skirt
it's true it's a skirt also when I wear
a tuxedo with the suspenders and I untie
the bowtie I know it's gonna be a red
panty night no red penny night just
means it means addressed it means we're
gonna it's gonna be a good night that's
what it means this is this is a term
that was been has been using our house
also Conor McGregor but yes it is like a
magnet that being said then we could say
that felt we could agree that's a little
bit societal because when we could go
back for the two men in tights you know
dressed like William Shakespeare and
most women would say that's silly
so that does change that's true but I
would challenge anybody to put on a suit
and a skirt and go out on a date and see
if they don't feel differently about
each other and look look at each other
different and have a more sexual
attraction and just the whole just the
whole nine yards I just think right now
I think there's I think there's a reason
that those period pieces Downton Abbey
and whatnot are so what made it that was
so awful because it's so retro
why on earth this is so popular why are
women women specifically by the way not
men women glued to those programs yes
are they singing they're seeing
something they don't have that they want
it's very obvious Mad Men would be
another example of that I mean this is
the you know Don Draper's a philandering
jerk but women like yeah I know but he's
so sexy
it's suits and the chiseled jawline
let's be honest you know that's
something you can't teach unfortunately
okay all right that is Suzanne thank
vent many laughing I know
vanie here man I keep saying don't say
Susan say Suzanne don't say fake I'm
cross Thames anchor Susie venture calm
the the twitter is suzanne venker hey
Suzanne I really appreciate you taking
the time I know we've gone over time and
I hope to have you hope you have to have
you back when this book is out here I am
drinking from my mug in a button-down
how often do you see this
never so do me
favor and yourself click one of these
videos playing in one of these boxes
here or a subscribe hit a notification
bell also because subscriptions don't
really mean a whole lot if you really
want to support the show join my club if
you don't then there's no helping you